[Music]
in the first
half of the year 1812
mount tambora began to rumble
the immense mountain had towered mutely
over the indonesian archipelago for
centuries
an entire culture growing and prospering
at its base
with trading links as far as cambodia
and vietnam
nearly 2 000 miles away on the distant
island of sumatra
sir stamford raffles the future founder
of singapore was stationed
on the 5th of april 1815 he reported the
sounds of distant gunshots
and troops were moved to counter the
supposed military threat
he struggled to sleep that night the
mysterious cannons still echoing in the
distance
and keeping him from his slumber
the next day however the true cause of
the blasts
was revealed a thin layer of ash
began to descend from the darkening
skies
over the next few days the heavens
blackened further still
and the atmosphere became stuffy and
close
as if before a great storm
and on the evening of the 10th of april
1815
1600 miles away mount
tambora exploded
this was an eruption the likes of which
had never before been seen by human eyes
nor has ever been seen since the
mountain became a flowing mass of liquid
fire with columns of flame reaching high
into the air
as the core of the volcano collapsed it
blew itself apart semi-molten volcanic
bombs the size of coconuts rained from
the heavens
scorching racing pyroclastic flows
cascaded down the mountainside
wiping the village of tambora off the
map
ten thousand people were killed and
another thirty five thousand
left homeless the entire culture and
language of the tambora people
was erased in days the eruption toward
the top of the mountain overnight
when the sun rose mount tambora was one
and a half kilometers shorter than the
day before
with a caldera more than six kilometers
across
but the sun didn't shine over indonesia
that day
or for many days after
stamford raffles reported taking his
breakfast by candlelight
the volcano disgorging 100 cubic
kilometers of rock and ash which filled
the air
and darkened the skies and as ash and
noxious gases lofted high into the
atmosphere
they were spread around the globe on jet
streams all over the planet the sun's
light and heat was blocked
a veil seeming to cover the sky global
temperature dropped by
three degrees celsius crops failed and
over the following year disease and
famine killed as many as 80
000 people as far away as europe
snow fell in june and 1816 became known
as the year without a summer
the climate altering blanket
immortalized in the dramatically
coloured sunsets
of turner's romantic landscapes
the tambora eruption of 1815 was the
largest
and most destructive volcanic eruption
in recorded history
its effects were catastrophic not only
to humans
but to the local ecosystem and global
climate
too natural catastrophes like this are
an inevitable consequence of the global
process
of plate tectonics but plate tectonics
itself
is shrouded in mystery what powers it
when did it start and how important
really is it it turns out
in the years following this brutal
eruption scientists discovered that as
terrible and destructive as its
consequences may be
plate tectonics could be the key
to keeping earth alive
[Music]
me
at the time of the great tambora
eruption geologists were still striving
to understand
how the surface of our planet really
worked
what created its mountains and ocean
basins
what caused the natural disasters if not
the wrath of the gods
the belief was that the surface of the
earth was a single
solid shell of rock yet nonetheless
there were clues hinting at colossal
invisible
processes that shaped that shell
in the 16th century it was dutch
cartographers
who first noticed the curious shapes of
our continents
shaped in such a way as to fit together
like pieces of a jigsaw puzzle
despite being separated by great swathes
of ocean
assuming they were once joined how did
these great fragments of rock become
separated the favored theory of the time
was that of
thermal cycles occasionally scientists
reasoned
the earth heated up and as warm objects
tend to expand so the earth expanded
cracking the crust and separating the
continents
but in 1915 alfred wegener
a german meteorologist proposed a new
theory
instead of thermal cycles separating
continents
land masses wandered around the earth
like immense icebreaker ships plowing
through the arctic basins
wegner's ideas were groundbreaking and
supported by a slew of new evidence
not only the previously seen jigsaw of
coastlines
but also the discovery of fossils of
similar creatures
found on continents oceans away
indeed when robert scott had made his
doomed expedition to the arctic several
years earlier
he and his men had found the fossils of
tropical rainforest beneath tundra
and frozen rock it was clear that the
continents had not only been separated
but had also
drifted from the equator to the poles
fitting the wegner's theory became known
as continental drift
but there was a problem despite the
evidence that it had indeed happened
wegner offered no explanation of how it
came about
what forces could move entire continents
and how did they make their way through
the solid rock
of the ocean floor without breaking
themselves up in the process
eventually wegner's ideas of continental
drift
lost favor but a seed had been sown for
an
entirely new theory one which took the
cutting edge of 20th century geophysics
to realize
in the 1960s a global network of
seismometers
was established for the first time
capable of pinpointing the epicentres
of deadly earthquakes and they revealed
something surprising
earthquakes didn't happen randomly all
over the earth's surface
but were confined to narrow strips
criss-crossing the globe sometimes these
strips follow the edges of continents
and sometimes
they cut right through the centers of
the oceans
together these earthquake-prone areas
defined the boundaries of more
stable slabs of rock those slabs are
what we now know as plates
with the earthquakes concentrated at
plate boundaries
where they grind and crash against one
another
new techniques to find the ages of rocks
and the orientation of their formation
added data to this new understanding of
plates
revealing how they shifted and changed
over time
and before long a new thesis emerged
with elements of the ideas that had gone
before the theory
of plate tectonics was born
the concept is a deceptively simple one
the rocks of the crust have lost
some of their heavier minerals so
they're less
dense than the mantle underneath
so they float on top like rafts of ice
on an arctic lake
continental rocks even more processed
than those in the oceans
and therefore even more buoyant
they can build up to huge heights and
still stay
afloat like towering icebergs
so the surface of the earth is covered
with these rock rafts
bumping and jostling for dominance but
they do more than that
the plates are constantly moving
shifting transforming where two plates
separate
magma rises to fill the gap hardening to
create brand new
rock adding to the diverging plates on
either side of the boundary
but growth of the plate can't go
unchecked where the two plates meet and
press against each other
the rocks can crumple folding and
breaking them into tortured
gargantuan heaps like the himalayas
the highest peaks of our world
[Music]
but eventually one plate triumphs in
this planetary struggle
it's density that decides the winner as
one rock raft will inevitably be
marginally more buoyant than another
the lighter rocks stand their ground at
the surface
while the heavier crust is forced down
bending
subducting into the mantle as the
heavier rock descends
it's heated and melts releasing its
minerals and water
that melt creates huge volumes of magma
enough to feed explosive volcanoes
like mighty mount tambora
as geologists study the surface of the
planet in ever more detail
all evidence seems to point to this slow
war of growth and destruction taking
place over geological
time scales but it's still not clear
what
powers this movement just as wegener
couldn't explain how continental drift
worked
scientists today are still struggling to
pinpoint the mechanisms
driving plate tectonics and how they got
started
and the constant recycling of rock means
that by its very nature
the process of plate tectonics masks
its own history
the core of our world is immensely hot
a remnant of its violent formation and
the decay of radioactive elements in the
center
that core is like a hot plate beneath a
pot of water
delivering its heat into the fluid rock
above
warmer mantles rise spread out cool
and sink back down creating huge
sideways currents beneath the crust
pushing it along but to truly understand
what powers plate tectonics
we need to look back to its very
beginnings
when the earth formed some four and a
half billion years ago
and in the early hadeon eon that
followed
nothing like modern plate tectonics
could have existed
the rocks were too hot too thoroughly
mixed by the convulsions of the
still-forming
battered earth the outer surface of the
planet froze into a single
solid shell while the interior remained
hot
and molten so instead of plate tectonics
a very different regime
must have rained
although the crust remained stubbornly
on the surface the heat from the mantle
still strove
to escape it warmed the base of that
crust and it became hotter and hotter
until that solid shell began to melt at
its base
gradually this molten rock dripped down
into the mantle
there it collects and is superheated
until it's hot enough with little enough
density
to come back up plumes of magma rising
up through the mantle
punching through the crust forging the
very first
volcanoes so instead of the circulating
currents of modern day plate tectonics
the early motion was almost
entirely vertical up and down
rather than what we have today
the vertical plumes are still somewhat
seen in our present
the hawaiian islands form part of a
chain of volcanoes formed by a plume of
magma
that has remained in place for 18
million years
but plate tectonics is now much more
dominant than this plume volcanism
so at some point in the last four
billion years
the earth's tectonic regime transformed
how it happened however is still
something
of a mystery scientists best guess
is that as the earth cooled the
compositions and temperatures of the
mantle and crust
gradually changed the crust became
weaker
fragmenting into small rafts the
precursor
to the modern plates if the edge of one
plate dipped below another
subduction could begin dragging the rest
of the raft after it
with the advent of subduction the heat
transfer in the mantle was given a
horizontal component for the first time
convection currents were established
which helped the sideways movement of
plates
making the process self-sustaining plate
tectonics
was born
though we might take it for granted it
seems like this ongoing tectonic process
is actually very rare in the cosmos
and we may have it to thank for our very
existence
on the earth for life
itself
[Music]
other nearby planets might have
geological activity
volcanoes and earthquakes but their
surfaces
aren't being recycled by plate tectonics
and other nearby planets are as far as
we know devoid of life
perhaps it's not such a coincidence that
both life and plate tectonics
are unique phenomena to our world
because the cycling of rock through the
earth's surface
also has an important impact on another
cycle
critical to life the carbon cycle
[Music]
life is made of organic carbon compounds
but it also relies on inorganic
carbon compounds like carbon dioxide to
keep the planet's temperature
at a habitable level trapping the heat
of the sun within the atmosphere
like an insulating blanket and carbon
dioxide is expelled from volcanoes when
they erupt
extra carbon dioxide pumped into the
atmosphere thickens the warming blanket
and increases global temperatures
but some of the carbon dioxide in the
air dissolves in the water droplets of
clouds
and before long rains out into rivers
lakes and oceans
all over the globe there it reacts with
rocks
breaking them down and making new ones
carbonates like
limestone and chalk much of the carbon
dioxide spewed out by volcanoes ends up
trapped
again locked up in the sedimentary rocks
of the earth's crust
but plate tectonics hasn't finished with
this carbon store
as the plates are consumed at converging
boundaries
the sedimentary rocks are also subducted
they melt and release carbon dioxide
back
into the magma to erupt from volcanoes
once again in this way carbon dioxide
levels in the atmosphere reach an
equilibrium providing an environment
that's not too hot
and not too cold for life to thrive
without it we could easily end up like
one of our barren
inhospitable planetary neighbors a dead
world
floating through the void
venus with plenty of volcanoes but no
tectonic recycling
witnessed the uncontrollable release of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
early in its existence some was locked
away
but when no further reactions could take
place levels of the greenhouse gas
continued to build oceans evaporated
and the rocks themselves altered to
release carbon back
into the atmosphere runaway heating
led to venus becoming the hottest planet
in our solar system
its surface more than 450 degrees
celsius
without plate tectonics the planet
baked to death
mars on the other hand suffered a
different but equally terminal fate the
red planet is smaller than the earth so
cooled quicker
there's evidence for volcanic activity
on the surface but this has slowed as
the planet aged
less and less carbon dioxide was
released into its atmosphere and what
was already there was gradually locked
away in its rocks or blown away by the
solar winds
without a way to recycle the carbon
stores mars was stripped of its
insulating blanket
and left out in the cold without plate
tectonics
the planet froze to death
so the recycling of carbon through the
earth's surface
helped to maintain a temperature just
right for life to get started
and thrive and plate tectonics probably
offered other benefits to a young earth
and its tentative first life forms too
the twisting and shifting of plates
across the earth's surface
created diverse environments and niches
for life to exploit
among these were hydrothermal vents
which form around the diverging
boundaries in the middle
of oceans it was around events like
these
that our last common ancestor found
refuge
while the earth was bombarded with
meteos in the early
archaean so
even though volcanic events like the
catastrophic 1815 eruption of mount
tambora
have the capacity to wreak havoc on
local ecosystems
and global climate they are an essential
part
of a wider process that is keeping our
planet
alive in this way plate tectonics could
just be
the key to making a planet
habitable
next time we'll investigate an
altogether more alien
explanation for life on earth we'll look
at the earliest fossils ever found on
our world
and we'll investigate what could have
happened had life
never evolved on our planet
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like and
subscribe and follow us on instagram to
keep up to date with the amazing artwork
produced for the show
and we'll see you next time